Every every local car company in China
is working on hybrids.
I'm in fact going back to a point,
you know Toyota makes it Prius,
hybrid now in China,
260,000 RMB.
Chung on a local car company makes a
hybrid,
so 160,000 RMB,
not as good as that Prius.
I guarantee you 100,000 RMB.
Cheaper.
Every single local car company and local
car companies account for 30 percent now
the passenger car business agenda,
the truck and bus business almost
completely local.
Okay.
There's no foreign company that has a
meaningful participation in that
commercial vehicle industry,
so there are a lot of local passenger
car companies,
trucking companies and so forth.
These lending companies that are all
thinking about the environment,
everybody's working on programs to
improve the fuel efficiency and the
environmental impact.
I think that the whole thinking about
the environment in China's mind switched
seven years ago when they announced that
Beijing would get the 2008 Olympics.
Think at that point,
every official in China realized that in
2008 for the first time,
millions of people coming to China and
they didn't want the environment to be
the big issue,
so there's a long way to go and believe
me,
China's got a huge environmental issue,
but the first step begins with thinking
differently about your.
I think that's already happened and so
everybody's conscious about it,
they're working on it.
A guarantee.
I think a lot of the new innovations in,
for example,
in the auto industry,
are going to come out of China.
Why?
Because there's no single country in the
world as a bigger vested interest in
getting that done.
Then China,
China needs to grow to lift up those
neither 1 million people to grow.
It needs more transportation.
If the more transportation,
the more pollution.
If it can't make available that
transportation,
if that's a constraint on growth.
So for China,
it's a matter of economic life and death
to find better ways to do it and that's
what I think is going to happen over the
next 10 years.